santiago muy buenos días buenos
uruguayos argentinos compartimos muchos
usos y costumbres y por supuesto tenemos
fuertes lazos económicos y culturales ya
desde hace muchos años de la fundación
de nuestros países en estos momentos
argentina que tiene una población de más
de 40 millones de personas se están
registrando más de 16.000 fallecidos por
el coronavirus mientras en uruguay donde
nuestra población es de más de tres
millones de casi tres millones y medio
de personas registramos 50 menos de 50
fallecidos por el coronavirus y esto ha
generado una atrás que haya sido más
atractivo el país para venir a recibir
de hecho en uruguay como tú ya sabes no
tenemos cuarentena obligatoria y la
mayoría de las actividades económicas se
encuentran en normalidad dentro del
marco de las medidas sanitarias por el
cobat 19 de hecho la cámara inmobiliaria
de uruguay ha dicho que se han
registrado múltiples solicitudes y de
hecho ha incrementado las compras
venta de propiedades de parte de
argentinos así también lo han indicado
los colegios privados donde recordemos
en uruguay sa se encuentran en clases
presenciales y en tiempo completo esto
ha sido un llamador para las familias
argentinas
karina del presidente de uruguay lacalle
pou dijo que se necesitaba más gente en
su territorio cuál es la razón
bueno el presidente lacalle pou ya en
enero antes de asumir dijo que iba a
implementar medidas para impulsar la
economía y también la generación de
empleo entre ellas la flexibilización de
la residencia fiscal de extranjeros dijo
que uruguay podía recibir 100 mil
familias y esto generar muy cosas
positivas para la economía uruguaya es
así que redujo está haciendo presidente
por ejemplo los requisitos de invertir
bajaron de 3.5 millones de dólares a 300
mil a 70 mil dólares y también menos
días 60 días de residencia y que se
genere 15 puestos de trabajo esto ha
generado una flexibilización para la
residencia fiscal no es tan fácil traer
las empresas pero algunos ya están
tomando estas medidas